ah so many people worked up over
chromosomes so I've got sort of a broad
question just to ask and kind of I don't
have a definitive answer for so I'm kind
of gonna at least not at my starting
point I'm gonna kind of work it through
talk it through with you folks and we'll
see where we end up how long should the
doctor stay a woman now a couple points
of clarification for what it is I'm
asking here I'm not saying I'm not
asking how long should Jodie Whittaker
play the dark Jodie Whittaker was gonna
play the doctor for however long she
plays the doctor at this point I expect
three years that's been there or yet
three series however many years that
ends up being but because three series
has become standard but what I mean is
should the next doctor after her be a
woman or being man or actually that's
not even really the question I'm asking
I'm not I'm not sure I want to come down
on the question of should or shouldn't
but I do kind of want to look at the
question of what will it mean if it's
another woman or if it's a man and this
is a question that I kind of wish I
didn't have to ask because I don't like
how politicized Doctor Who and Doctor
Who fandom has become but the simple
truth is that that's happened whether I
like it or not almost everything the
show does is put into a political
context whether it is intended to be by
the makers or not and the makers
themselves at least of the current than
you know the current creative team
behind it have been upfront with some
intent to cover political topics and
touch on political things in the show
so and and but again even that's not a
successively new the shows been
political in the past I've talked about
that before but overall like I I I want
I want to talk this out because it's in
my head and unfortunately we're in a
situation where either option is going
to have knock-on effects and it's going
to upset somebody but then again the
state of doctor venom right now is such
that almost anything they do is going to
upset somebody so the the first thing I
would say is the fear of upsetting or
pleasing any specific stripe a fan
should not be driving the decision to
cast a man or a woman
I don't believe personally because like
I said at this point things have become
so divided that you're gonna tick off
somebody so you might as well do the
decision that you feel the most
confident in in terms of casting and
creativity because you know if you're
trying to if you're trying to please the
fans well the fans are already fighting
amongst themselves in terms of what they
want so you that's not gonna work yeah
and that's not to say you should go out
of your way to antagonize fans but when
you try and please a fan base especially
a fan base that isn't particularly
unified you're just gonna end up
compromising whatever it is you do but
we're kind of looking at one of two
situations so like just let's just talk
broadly here if after Jodie Whittaker
leaves the doctor is again a woman there
is going to be a stripe of fan who is
going to be upset by that and continue
to how agenda pushing who are gonna say
you're just keeping it a woman to please
or you know to satisfy whatever agenda
or fans that you were pandering to
before so on and so for
so basically the if if the next doctor
were to also be a woman at least
initially barring a change in creative
team and overall approach because I'd
like to think that if we if we if and
when we eventually get a new showrunner
and a new sort of mentality behind the
show that comes with a new showrunner
that people who haven't liked Chibnall
run will give it another shot even if
they cast a woman again I'd like to
think that I don't know how true it is
though but the people who are upset on
the basis of the doctor should never be
a woman will just continue to be upset
and so you won't regain that but like
that's an audience that's already or at
least they claim to already not be
watching the show yeah at the same time
like I said like is it overly
antagonizing I don't know the flipside
and I think potentially more damaging
ultimately if a man is cast immediately
after Jody would occur I really do worry
that that is going to get read as well
it's gonna be read as a weird victory by
some fans and others like the show is
admitting defeat
on some things and again I don't feel
that that should be the case but that is
how some people are going to react to it
if it goes that way and it's I I don't
envy whether it ends up being Chris
Chibnall or somebody else whoever has to
make the decision of who to cast the
nest the next doctor I do not envy them
that position at all
because they are they are literally
going to be in a no-win scenario as far
as the fandom is concerned because like
I said it's so split and it's and it's
so hostile that and that's the thing
like fan bases are always fan bases are
never unified about what they want what
they like what's the best stuff but it's
become so angry that whatever side you
don't please is now up in arms about it
as opposed to just going that wasn't
what I wanted and you know just not
watching it's not enough to just not
watch anymore
I don't know what should happen because
[Music]
there's again taking whoever the
potential casting is out of the equation
because like hypothetically I don't know
who but hypothetically maybe there is a
casting that is so loved that it won't
matter I don't know who that would be
but I mean not that I think any of this
is realistic alright I may eventually do
a video on people who I think would be
good people to play the doctor but I'm
not doing that now but like if they if
they cast I don't know Idris Elba
Michael Fassbender James McAvoy if they
cast like somebody that got everybody
excited just by oh my god that person
holy cow um Emma Thompson you know Helen
Mirren whole like I feel like short of
casting names like that whatever happens
is gonna end up dividing the fan base I
do think that casting like that might be
the only way to minimise fallout that is
otherwise
gonna happen regardless of whether the
next doctor is a man or a woman but I
can't I can't hold out hope that they
would do that kind of casting not that
any of the people I named are like too
good for TV because especially in
Britain there you get a lot more of a
film stars appearing and television
shows over there
I mean Hechinger celibate just did
another series of Luther but at the same
time even that it's usually shorter six
episodes to a series a series whenever
we get around to a type shows like
Luther like Sherlock and for something
that is traditionally and kind of
expected to be released on more like an
annual schedule that's already been
thrown off but you know what I'm saying
we don't get the same level of actors in
to play the the leads in 13 episodes a
year plus massive publicity for the same
thing it basically means that this is
the only thing they're gonna be doing
for however long they do it and I don't
see any of those any of the names of
that size being willing to do that and
short of a name like that I just don't
know it depresses me to think that no
matter what somebody's going to be angry
and again while I accept you can't
please everybody it just bums me out to
know that this anger and these fights
and the mudslinging and the name-calling
isn't going to change when the next
casting happens no matter what it's not
going to change and I am ending up on a
much more depressed note than I thought
I would when I set out to do this video
if I were to make for myself an ultimate
conclusion short of getting you know a
performer or an actor for the role who
is so universally good that everybody it
silences everybody short of that I think
one more series or sorry one more
incarnation as a woman will be the
better way to go before opening up to go
back to a male doctor and I say that
because I don't like the idea that the
female doctor becomes regarded as either
a novelty or a mistake you know a thing
that we don't we we're not gonna go back
and do again and like and and even if
people do feel that it was a mistake
again ideally not on the basis of just
because it's a woman but if people do
feel that you know this was a mistake
whether it's the writing or that Jodie
Whittaker wasn't up to the task or
whatever else I get that but I it
doesn't sit right with me personally the
idea that the notion of ever expanding
out doctor
casting wise gets looked at as a fluke
like I I just don't like the idea of
that and that's not me saying like it
can never be a white man again of course
I'm not saying that
and and I'm also not gonna pitch a fit
if after would occur they cast a guy a
white guy any guy like I'll be as open
to it as I always am which is
sceptically as a rule of thumb but you
know I just talking just completely
broad starts talking philosophically I
feel like whatever was meant to be
accomplished by having a woman any woman
to play the doctor gets potentially
buried if immediately after it goes back
to a man again because then maybe it
stays that forever and it's just a weird
blip on the radar and if if this would I
was gonna say if this was gonna happen
it has happened and having now cast a
woman doctor I'd like that to mean
something and I think possibly to ensure
that it does mean anything we might need
one more woman after Whitaker and again
that's talking broad philosophical Oh
God the comment section on this is gonna
be a nightmare isn't it don't know why I
still try sometimes I'm gonna stop here
because like I said I'm getting more
bummed out thinking about all the
fallout that's gonna happen to the
casting whatever it is whenever it
happens and to this video whenever I
release it I just want us to have fun
again we do that please
dr. who future casting please please
don't leave me with a hundred comments
that automatically get flagged because
of the names that people get called okay
just please be respectful within those
parameters whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it whatever your
thoughts are just keep them respectful
and there's a whole bunch of links down
there too one to my patreon of course I
have one of those it helps there's a PA
box there's a bunch of other stuff check
it out if you want to if you don't
that's okay so at the end of the day you
are the council I just run the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]